avoir la sentinelle 97: 3 vous donne beaucoup
de volume spatial lorsque la
foule réagit, vous pouvez dire qu'ils
regardent quelque chose de physique, ils sont
tous concentrés sur la même chose,
vous obtenez également toutes les
réflexions de tous  les gens en plastique peuvent se tenir
devant ou derrière et marcher
autour, ils peuvent laisser tomber les choses que vous
ne pourriez pas faire si vous aviez juste un
bâton vert là-bas et dire aux
gens d'imaginer ce qu'il y a ici la seule scène
où ces  saute et essaie de
désactiver une sentinelle en arrachant ses
fils de son cou, nous lui tirons dessus pratiquement,
nous avons un cascadeur maquillé de bête qui
saute sur une forme de robot vert géant
qui est sur un cardan poussant d'avant en
arrière et il est éjecté  par fils,
ils étaient très primitifs relativement
parlant
ce que la mystique offre dans son ADN, c'est
qu'ils peuvent prendre ses pouvoirs prendre l'
essence de son pouvoir incorporé avec des
sandales maintenant les deux côtés veulent trouver la
mystique un côté veut protéger  son
ADN pour sauver les mutants et l'autre
côté veut prendre son ADN pour détruire
les mutants ses gènes pourraient détenir la clé
de la mutation elle-même imaginer des sentinelles
qui pourraient se transformer s'adapter à n'importe quelle cible la
confiance vole le code génétique de Mystique
et il utilise sa génétique qu'elle
fabrique essentiellement  des versions géantes d'elle ce qu'elle est
capable de faire parce qu'il la voit comme
cette espèce parfaite et s'il peut d'une
manière ou d'une autre lui voler ses capacités, les réseaux sociaux
fonctionneront beaucoup de gens dans les différentes incarnations de x-men
ont voulu utiliser les
Sentinelles c'est tellement énorme  une partie de la tradition x-men
une sentinelle est une énorme
arme robotique qui cherche et détruit
il y a eu tellement de films de robots que la
difficulté de le faire est d'être originale
car elle doit être très familière
aux fans qui ont lu la bande dessinée la
chose  que nous avons que je ne crois pas
qu'aucun autre film jamais réalisé ne montre des
incarnations technologiques de ce à quoi
ressemble un robot dans le passé et
quel que soit mon potentiel dans  l'
avenir où je voulais rester aussi fidèle
que possible aux Sentinelles alors que nous avons traversé l'
histoire, la première chose que
j'ai faite a été de créer un livre qui montrait à
quoi ressemblait le Sénat et la
première fois que vous l'avez vu, puis chacun
année et sous forme de bande dessinée, ils fonctionnent à
merveille, mais beaucoup d'entre eux
ressemblaient à des lutteurs des années 1950 pour nous